[Music]
uh this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
so far hundreds of challengers
no winners no one's ever found us making
a mistake
yeah because we don't make them
anywho tonight a fan named tim blasis
thinks he caught a mistake he says it
happened last week after skydiver felix
baumgartner set a new record for the
world's highest free fall
well we in turn on the show set a record
for the world's shortest free fall
that is where tim says we screwed up
hello conan my name is tim washes and
i'm a physicist that
got his undergrad degree from the
university of michigan and now i'm in a
phd program at caltech and
i couldn't help but notice a physics
error you made on last tuesday's show
when you claim to have an assistant
perform the world's shortest freefall
daredevil alex brenner suspended four
inches from the ground
too one
ball
[Music]
truly awe inspiring airborne for six one
thousandth of a second you claim that
your assistant fell
four inches in six one thousandths of a
second and i'm here to derive for you
that that is physically impossible
okay
so we know the acceleration of your
system which is of course the second
derivative with respect to time of
position uh was g which is the
acceleration due to gravity at the
earth's surface
that we can integrate to get velocity so
in order to solve for time all we need
to know is g
and
the
distance that he found
i can calculate the velocity with which
he struck the ground
uh his i can get his real acceleration
and then
freak us off with t and i find that
0.14 seconds that means you were off by
a factor of 24. now i realize that in
your world it may be normal for things
to happen 24 times faster than expected
in the bedroom maybe this is fundamental
physics
sorry tim
but you are so wrong it's sad and i'm
gonna prove it right now
i took the liberty of reproducing your
calculations precisely now we all know
that acceleration is the second
derivative of position with respect to
time d squared x divided by dt squared
which makes the first derivative of
velocity the d times v divided by d
times t but then tim you state that g
equals the acceleration due to gravity
at the earth's surface as if the air
resistance at every point on the earth's
surface is uniform for god's sake man
do your homework
by failing to take into account the drag
force is created by the specific
pressure that exists here in warner
brothers sound stage 15 you not only
embarrass yourself you embarrass the
entire caltech community
let's just say that the nature of these
unique sound stage forces combines
shockwave effects vortex systems
generation effects and weight viscous
mechanisms into a motion equation that's
clearly beyond the scope of your limited
understanding
now so to clarify you're saying d
squared g times the square root of x no
andy we've been over this
i'm talking d squared t squared g
squared v times the cube root of x
divided by y to the nth power times the
sine of the cosine of the tangent of z
oh my god you're right yes
well i'm sorry tim but you blew it even
the basset hound on the wall behind you
is laughing
yeah
yeah
yeah
and if you don't believe me let's check
in with the world's greatest physicist
and see what he thinks
hey tim
you're wrong
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so the challenge still stands if you
think you've spotted an error on our
show reported at teamcoco.com
haha i found an error we will sort it
out right here on the air let's see if
you got what it takes to make chuck meat
out of the maestro